sometimes in life what isn't said is
more important than what is said
and if you ever thought conservatives
complaints about the gop establishment
were all overblown well the past day
should have disabused you of that notion
27 hours after we first learned about
the fbi's raid of the home of former
president trump
and top republican leaders in the senate
still kind of seem unsure how to react
the senate minority leader who hates
trump seemed bothered not by the raid
but by the question about the raid
i'm here today to talk about the flood
and the recovery from the flood
then at 7 pm tonight 24 hours after we
learned of the raid and after a barrage
of complaints from the conservative base
mcconnell finally offered the bare
minimum of what should have been said
all along
the country deserves a thorough and
immediate explanation of what led to the
events of monday garland the department
of justice should already have provided
answers to the american people and must
do so immediately
south dakota's jon thune mcconnell's de
facto deputy tweeted today about the fun
things that are happening at the sioux
falls fair
wyoming's john barrasso the chair of the
senate gop tweeted another rather mild
observation saying raiding a former
president's home is unprecedented the
justice department needs to quickly and
transparently tell the american people
who approved this raid and why it
occurred
i mean no kidding
now i like some of these guys personally
they're not all bad people but the angle
is about the business of saving the
country
and if top republicans believe that this
millimouthed response that they're
giving is the way to win back power and
then keep power
they are sorely mistaken
now we know the republican establishment
has nothing but disdain for trump they
tolerated him didn't they when he was
president but they couldn't wait for him
to have his comeuppance
but the problem here for the
establishment is that now the voters are
on to their game
and they realize that if they don't
stand up for trump now
well they'll never stand up for the
american middle class
this is a huge miscalculation for the
senate's gop leadership
and not the first time they've stepped
in it on strategy
remember these same geniuses of
legislative maneuvering are fresh off of
a massive legislative screw-up on that
tax and irs and climate change bill
they gave the democrats a glide path to
this week's big win by voting for the
democrats 1.2 trillion dollar so-called
infrastructure bill earlier last year
my staff and i have read it totally
and
defending it my gosh why wouldn't you
want this as one of my colleagues said
why didn't why not do what pelosi did
and say
let show us your hand first let's see
the full text of your
uh reconciliation bill everything that's
in a climate change amnesty tax
increases all the the the nightmares
that we already delineated tonight let
them show their hand but it got flipped
didn't it you guys got played on this
you had to vote first or agree first
they still haven't shown the text of
their legislation have they sir
the ironic thing is you are agreeing
with the squad and bernie it's amazing
you are agreeing with pelosi when they
passed the 3.5 trillion you're going to
come back on the show and say you were
wrong
oh so so in some way
even though we've made an i'll come back
on the show but even though we've made
it less possible if it still happened
somehow this is the blame now that logic
is specious and you know that
well maybe not the 3.5 trillion but you
get the point just as the angle
predicted these fools gave biden the
cover of a bipartisan victory and now
the democrats will unleash an 87 000
person army of irs agents against
conservative americans from every corner
of the country
these republicans set the stage for this
nightmare and they don't have the
decency to now state the obvious
the biden people are exacting revenge
against trump not for january 6 but
because they're afraid that if he wins
in 2024 he'll finally drain the swamp
the swamp that the bipartisan cabal has
been happy to luxuriate in for decades
well my friends
those days are coming to an end hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else